Vamos a seguir trabajando
con sistemas de ecuaciones por eliminación,
sin embargo en esta ocasión,
vamos a tener que trabajar un poco nuestras ecuaciones antes de que se eliminen las variables,
es decir, vamos a preparar a nuestras ecuaciones
antes de que se puedan eliminar,
pero bueno, vamos a escribir
nuestras ecuaciones,
en este caso voy a jugar con
"5x" menos "10y" esto igual a 15
y me voy a tomar otra ecuación,
la ecuación,  "3x" menos "2y"...
"3x" menos "2y" esto igual a 3.
Y lo primero que quiero
que te des cuenta
es que hay varias formas de resolver
este tipo de ecuaciones,
podríamos resolver por sustitución,
podríamos graficarlo
y resolver el sistema buscando
el punto de intersección,
sin embargo, si yo quisiera utilizar
el método de suma y resta,
entonces lo que hay que hacer
es sumarle o restarle una ecuación,
lo mismo de ambos lados.
Y bueno,
en el video pasado lo que hacíamos
era tomarme la parte izquierda
de estas dos ecuaciones, sumarlas
y después tomarme la parte derecha
de estas ecuaciones y también sumarlas,
sin embargo, si te das cuenta,
si yo sumo o resto
estas dos ecuaciones,
no voy a poder eliminar
ninguna de estas variables,
mi resultado va a quedar tanto en términos de "x"
como en términos de "y",
entonces,
¿qué podemos hacer?
Y bueno, la respuesta es que vamos a multiplicar 1
o ambas ecuaciones por una constante
de tal manera
que después de hacer esto,
se puedan cancelar por eliminación
y bueno,
lo primero que debes hacer es elegir
una variable para cancelarla,
así que vamos a decir que
quiero eliminar a la "y".
Para eliminar a la "y" date cuenta que
aquí tenemos "10y" y abajo tenemos "2y",
así que déjame primero copiar la ecuación
que tenemos arriba
"5x" menos "10y" igual a 15
y ahora fíjate en esta ecuación de aquí abajo.
Si la multiplicamos por alguna constante,
y bueno,
hay que saber que constante,
habrá alguna forma que cuando nosotros multipliquemos por esta constante
y la sumemos a esta ecuación
que tenemos de amarillo,
se pueda eliminar la variable "y",
y bueno, la respuesta es que sí,
porque fíjate,
aquí tengo un "2y",
de hecho tengo un "-2y",
para que se cancele
tendría que ser "10y" positivo,
porque date cuenta que
en la ecuación de amarillo tenemos un "-10y",
entonces para que se cancele,
abajo tendría que quedar "10y" positivo
y para que la ecuación de abajo
se convierta en un "10y" positivo
hay que multiplicarla por -5
y ojo,  vamos a multiplicar
toda la ecuación tanto el lado izquierdo,
como el lado derecho para que así
no se altere la ecuación,
no se altere la igualdad.
Así que vamos a hacerlo,
-5 por "3x" es "-15x"...
"-15x" después me queda menos por menos, más,
es justo lo que queríamos,
5 por 2 = 10,
"10y",
es justo lo que queríamos
y al final me queda 3 por -5 lo cual es -15.
Y está perfecto,
porque ahora ya tenemos "-10y" más "10y"
y si nosotros sumamos
estas dos ecuaciones,
entonces se va a cancelar
todo lo que tiene que ver con "y"
que justo esa era la idea para nosotros utilizar
el método de suma y resta o el método de eliminación,
es decir, lo que queríamos era cancelar
una de estas variables
y si sumamos estas dos ecuaciones
se va a cancelar todo lo que tiene
que ver con "y",
¿y qué me quedaría?
"5x" menos "15x" pues esto es lo mismo que "-10x",
no olvides que aquí teníamos un
menos
y por lo tanto 5 menos 15
es -10, "-10x",
"-10y" más "10y"
justo era lo que queríamos,
que se cancelaran,
entonces estas dos se van,
se hacen 0,
y entonces solamente me queda "-10x"
del lado izquierdo de esta ecuación,
mientras que del lado derecho me queda
15 menos 15 lo cual es 0.
Y bueno, si de aquí queremos despejar a "x",
lo que voy a hacer es dividir ambos lados de la ecuación
entre -10,
me va a quedar que "x" es igual
a 0 entre -10,
pero 0 entre -10 es 0.
Y date cuenta cómo ya habíamos encontrado una ecuación con solamente una incógnita
y con esto logramos encontrar la "x",
el valor de "x" es "x" igual a 0
y una vez que ya tengo este valor de "x",
lo que voy a hacer es sustituirlo
en la primera ecuación,
para encontrar el valor de "y".
Y me queda 5 por 0 se va
y entonces me queda
que "-10y" es igual a 15,
ya sé que "x" vale 0
y entonces si divido ambos lados entre -10,
voy a obtener el valor de "y",
estos dos se van
y me queda que "y" es igual
a 15 entre -10, lo cual es -3/2...
-3/2...
Y perfecto, ya tengo el valor
para "x" y para "y"
que solucionan esta ecuación,
"x" igual a 0 y "y" igual a -3/2
ó dicho de otra manera, el punto 0, -3/2
es el punto de intersección de estas dos rectas
o son los valores de la solución
de estas dos ecuaciones.
Y bueno, pues vamos a ver
si también cumple la segunda ecuación,
así que vamos a sustituir,
3 por 0, menos 2 por "y",
pero "y" vale -3/2,
-2 por -3/2 esto tiene que ser igual a 3,
3 por 0 es 0,
menos por menos me da más
y estos dos se van
y solamente me queda 3,
más 3 es 3
y perfecto, la comprobación
de la segunda ecuación sí queda.
Y muy bien,
ya con eso tengo la comprobación.
Ahora lo que quiero hacer
es resolver otro problema
que tenga que ver igual con eliminación
o con suma y resta,
pero que no sea directa,
que tengamos que multiplicar por alguna constante
para que entonces
podamos resolver el sistema.
Así que, pues déjame poner
otro par de ecuaciones
y me voy a tomar
las siguientes ecuaciones.
"5x" más "7y" igual a 15
y después voy a poner aquí abajo con otro color,
"7x" menos "3y"
esto lo voy a hacer igual a 5
y quiero resolver
este sistema de ecuaciones.
Ahora date cuenta
que si lo vamos a resolver por eliminación,
no podemos sumar las ecuaciones
de una manera inmediata
porque entonces no se eliminarían
ninguna de las dos variables
y entonces es cuando se me ocurre multiplicar
por una constante, ya sea la ecuación de
arriba o ya sea la ecuación de abajo o ambas
y de hecho, si te das cuenta, en esta ocasión
teníamos que multiplicar ambas,
pero antes de eso,
recuerda que lo que tenemos que hacer
es elegir una de las dos variables para cancelar.
En este caso la "y" es negativa y sería mucho
más fácil cancelarla, sin embargo,
vamos a trabajar con la "x"
para hacerlo mucho más divertido.
Así que quiero cancelar la "x"
y para cancelar la "x",
podría multiplicar cualquiera de estas dos ecuaciones
por una fracción,
de tal manera que al volverla negativa,
se cancelara con este "7x" ó con este "5x",
sin embargo,
para no trabajar con fracciones,
lo cual no va a ser nada grato, lo que voy a hacer es
buscar el mínimo común múltiplo entre 5 y 7,
para que así, pueda ir guiando ambas ecuaciones
a ese mínimo común múltiplo,
que por cierto es 35,
y bueno, si yo lo que quiero convertir es
"5x" a 35,
tengo que multiplicar
la ecuación de arriba por 7,
para que me quede
7 por 5 = "35x"
y la de abajo por 5,
pero por 5 negativo,
de tal manera que al multiplicar
-5 por 7 me quede "-35x"
y ya con esto voy a poder
eliminar la variable "x"
y entonces voy a lograr
tener una ecuación
con solamente una incógnita
y muy fácil
de resolver,
si lo hago por
el método de eliminación.
Ojo, esto es muy común
cuando utilizas el método de suma y resta,
cruzas los coeficientes
para que así se pueda eliminar una variable.
Así que pues vamos a hacerlo.
¿Si multiplico la ecuación de arriba por 7
qué me va a quedar?
7 por 5 pues es 35, "35x",
entonces vamos a anotarlo,
"35x"
y después me queda 7 por 7,
7 por 7 es 49,
"49y"
y por último me queda 7 por 15,
7 por 15 es lo mismo que 70
más 35 que es 105,
ojo, recuerda que hay que
multiplicar toda la ecuación por 7,
tanto el lado izquierdo
de la igualdad, como el lado derecho de la igualdad.
Y bueno,
vamos a hacer lo mismo para la ecuación de abajo,
voy a multiplicarla por -5,
tanto del lado izquierdo, como del lado derecho,
¿y qué me va a quedar?
-5 por "7x" es "-35x",
menos por menos me da más,
5 por 3 me da 15, "15y",
más "15y"
y del otro lado me queda
5 por -5,
5 por --5 es -25.
Y ahora si, date cuenta que ya tenemos
el mismo coeficiente al lado de la "x"
y no solo eso,
uno es positivo y el otro es negativo,
por lo tanto cuando yo sume estas dos ecuaciones,
se va a eliminar todo lo que tiene que ver con "x",
que es justo lo que queríamos para
resolver esta ecuación por el método de suma y resta,
así que vamos a sumar estas
dos ecuaciones
de tal manera que se elimine todo
lo que tenga que ver con "x".
Y dice, "35x" menos "35x", se va,
"49y" más "15y" esto es lo mismo que 54 más 10,
"64y"...
"64y" esto es igual a 105 menos 25,
5 menos 5 es 0, 100 menos 20 es 80.
Y aquí ya tengo una ecuación con
solamente una incógnita muy fácil de resolver,
si divido ambos lados entre 64,
me queda que "y" es igual a 80 entre 64,
64 y 64 me da 1,
entonces solamente me queda "y"
y del otro lado, 80 entre 64,
que por cierto, le podemos
sacar octava tanto arriba como abajo,
si yo divido 80 entre 8 me va a dar 10
y 64 entre 8 me da 8,
por lo tanto me quedaría 10 sobre 8...
10 sobre 8 que por cierto ambos tienen mitad,
entonces esto es lo mismo que 5/4.
Ya tengo el valor de "y",
el valor de "y"que resuelve ambas ecuaciones simultáneamente es igual a 5/4,
pero ojo,
no olvidemos que no he acabado el problema,
ya tengo el valor de "y",
sin embargo todavía no tengo el valor de "x",
así que para sacar a "x" tengo que
elegir una de estas dos ecuaciones
y vamos a elegir la segunda ecuación,
así que vamos a sustituir el valor de "y".
Y me queda,
"7x" menos "3y" esto es igual a 5,
pero en lugar de y" voy a poner el valor de "y",
"y" vale 5/4 por lo tanto
voy a sustituir a "y" por 5/4,
que es mi solución en esta ecuación.
Y me queda "7x" menos 3 por 5/4, esto es igual a 5,
"7x" menos 15/4 esto es igual a 5...
no, esperen, esperen, esperen...
¿Qué estoy haciendo?
Aquí hay algo raro,
déjenme borrar todo esto
porque aquí me suena que algo está mal,
dice 3 por 4....
no, no, no, no, esperen, si estoy bien...
si estoy bien...
Oh, ¿qué estoy haciendo?
Es 3 por 5 = 15 entre 4,
15/4, esto es igual a 5,
"7x" menos 15/4 es igual a 5,
y ahora sí,
voy a sumar 15/4 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
entonces más 15/4,
más 15/4 del lado izquierdo,
estos dos se cancelan y solamente me queda,
"7x", 15/4 y -15/4 se van
y del lado derecho me queda 5 más 15/4,
pero 5 es lo mismo que 20/4,
entonces lo voy a escribir como
20/4 mas 15/4 y 20/4 más 15/4...
déjame bajar un poco la pantalla,
esto es lo mismo que 35/4,
entonces "7x" es igual  a 35/4
y ahora voy a multiplicar todo por 1/7
ó dicho de otra manera, voy a dividir todo entre 7
y entonces vamos a dividir esta parte entre 7
ó lo que es lo mismo multiplicado por 1/7
y de tal manera que estos dos se van
y solamente me queda "x"
mientras que del lado derecho,
35 se puede dividir entre 7 y me da 5
y entonces solamente me queda, 5/4,
"x" es igual a 5/4,
"y" es igual a 5/4...
¡Wow! Los dos valores son los mismos,
es decir, que la solución de este
sistema de ecuaciones es "x" igual a 5/4,
"y" igual a 5/4 ó dicho de otra manera,
la intersección de estas dos rectas es el punto 5/4, 5/4.
Y bueno,
vamos a checar o a comprobar
en la primera ecuación que realmente
si llegamos al resultado correcto
y dice 5 por "x" pero "x" vale 5/4,
5 por 5/4 más 7 por "y"
pero "y" vale 5/4, más 7 por 5/4,
esto tiene que ser igual a 15.
Vamos a ver si sí.
5 por 5/4 es lo mismo que 25/4,
7 por 5 = 35,
entonces me queda 35/4 y 25/4 más 35/4
es lo mismo que 60/4,
lo cual es 15, perfecto,
que es justo lo que queríamos.
Acabamos de comprobar en la primera ecuación.
Y bueno,
tú puedes verificar en la ecuación de abajo,
sin embargo no es tan necesario
porque justo de aquí salió que "x" vale 5/4.
Así que nos vemos en el siguiente video.